here we go against yacht bird
Grandmaster leubronn yeah I'm going for
kings in linear had a good add some good
games with that against him faring
better with that somehow then with them
more solid openings what is he doing 92
hmm shall I go for this the gung-ho
attack here f5 and so on let's try that
simply throwing caution to the winds and
attack answer as sharp as possible g-53
I think it's like this right should be
three and what are they doing now I
think this right b5 and now they take if
i'm not mistaken wow this is like one of
the most brutal opening lines possible
if he goes on d6 i probably play Bishop
f8 for this for this pin on the bishop
there I'm not sure this is almost a
theoretical line maybe it is it is an
online
Jim
let's see how we place that are in his
excellent dynamic player especially if
he has the initiative but this is more
like something where I have the
initiative so okay I'm going for g3 here
h3 I think can I not just take then I
mean h3 Bishop h3 isn't this isn't this
all in let's see this looks super
dangerous for wine I really would hate
to play this this kind of thing with the
with wide um okay so if i take them i
guess i guess i'm taking it's going to
each one like they usually do and what
now aged 49 h 593 or is there something
something better yeah come on let's do
that let's not make it too sophisticated
and spent spent a long time here so
night age five i guess that is the idea
Wow quickly played him nigeria and h3
this looks super dangerous
or h3 immediately this is maybe that's
even better I think he's angling for 97
and wonder ever should take for that I
think I should take first actually to
prevent a check only seven he can go 96
really this is not a big big issue if he
takes the rook or something I'm going
i'm shooting for mating attack here
anyway so what about this age three i
receive how is he defending this thing
night f7 tweenage for i mean this is
like super dangerous ok let's go for
them
yeah so Queen age for or taking what is
better it both looked both both looks
terrible to be honest if I take them on
on on on g2 or queen edge for Queen each
form looks more attractive actually
Kings how is he not getting checkmated
there I don't get it 97 maybe 97
you can also take g2 and play Bishop age
three check to do it with checks the
whole sequence but I don't see a win
there okay let's do this let's do this
to see go for 97's what I think you see
97 if I take it that squinty aid so
nitey 7 i'm blanking age 7
that should be good for me I mean I'm a
rope down I know but still I don't see
how he defends this absolutely not some
kind of desperado was g4 I don't know I
don't see a defense maybe I should have
taken first on g2 this is this as
possible maybe that was stronger even
hmm what is he going to do a G hole or
something I think I'll just take the
pawn jackal saw ya came here no no big
choice no yeah but this is chick made
this is checkmate check check check and
93 check made or cringey to be sure
pastries white resins yeah attacking him
with some some pure aggression yes is
better than sitting around and let him
do the attack it seems I had one
comparable game in the Kings Indian
we're also got a meeting attack I really
don't know about the objective merit of
this year but it is dangerous without
any question so g3 he went rookie one
yeah interesting and here there are own
I ok the computer already finds forced
wins for me after he won ok yeah ok h3
is a move but I take yeah this is
something that I already mentioned
during the video the thing is that after
Teague's I'm going to just attack the
pawn and she cannot defend it and I'm
going queen age 39 age 41 checkmate them
the only way to avoid the immediate made
is rook f2 now which cannot be the
solution to the whole thing I'm just in
exchange up here computer even likes
this move more this is a very very cute
move you're letting this hang and
attacking this and if white takes this
is easy going to be much stronger
because now I'm threatening still the
checkmate attack very nice and in
addition I'm going to be an exchange up
yeah ruki one what what is he supposed
to play the computer gifts but the comp
have to be a bit cautious there those
attacks are sometimes beyond the
computers horizon it gives about zero
with Roxy to Roxy too tough to analyze
him I mean I can definitely just move
the night like here and go for this
which looks I mean more than scary I
don't think that this can be played hard
looks too scary yeah okay after this I
went I went here simply because I didn't
want to spend too much time the the
engine is giving night eggs what does it
give as beasts b6 first yeah that looks
like a very good move actually yeah
because the bishop doesn't have any good
square so like here here Bishop back and
now BAM is already over and suck in this
over yeah that's really strong meeting
on edge to this is when winning ups
automatically and if he takes takes I'm
still threatening made so he has to
capture and this attack is going to be
decisive night comes here and before and
everything yeah computers r minus five
here so check and this this is probably
second second best but still very
dangerous Jim and now he went quite
quickly for the g6 their counter play
maybe okay I go I go here and I think I
okay so here's the point night h5 is not
good it's not good i should have played
h3 this is not good because of 95 is not
the point but taking yeah to be honest i
overlooked something very simple here my
idea was if he takes i thought okay this
is not really important I'm going 25 but
Queen dat is pretty good right just win
so after the capture I cannot do that
that means i have to play something like
a queen d worn or or this which is
completely ridiculous so i made a huge
mistake there but he played this very
quickly
and after that I think he's going down I
don't think this is defensible a Quincy
five was in fact stronger yeah I don't
know i s-saw Queen g5 of course it's a
normal move but I was thinking why not
prevent this thing however this is again
very strong just like in the game here
in fact 9066 h3 the engine gives g3 as
something that that is not losing right
away and in fact should is supposed to
be good for what this is no you cannot
make me believe that one so this is the
engine suggestion not this this losses
ok but this ok I I thought about this
move briefly but I couldn't believe it
so I'm taking with the pawn and now the
engine wants to go F form
and it gives why the slight advantage
hmm yeah that's probably probably
difficult it is haha what a position
it's completely crazy yeah that's
completely crazy so he went here and I
went here and now I'm really winning it
is nothing to do them yeah even could
have taken taken this o night c8 all
night f5 is still possible so taking was
stronger yeah I wasn't really paying
paying so much attention as I saw this
is wins I haven't I couldn't believe
that you can defend this I'm honored
with everything but night xc8 is not a
check made
check at least the engine is not seeing
one check it's now on 10 now it gives a
slight edge for black yeah impossible
and this is just impossible to analyze
like in like in a couple of minutes it's
just it just utterly crazy and in blitz
you just have to go with your instincts
check yeah he went for the check and
here he took which is really just made
yeah I think he's more likely to make a
mistake if he's under heavy attack then
in a situation where where he has got
the initiative via he really AM is very
strong if he's got the attack but in in
defense I have won a couple of nice
games against him okay well thanks for
watching